phil fontaine est un territoire plutôt
connue au vatican l'ancien chef de
l'assemblée des premières nations n'en
est pas une première visite du saint
siège demain ce sera sa troisième
rencontre avec le pape
les rencontres à rome et l'importante
attention médiatique qui leur sont
portés confirme aussi selon phil
fontaine que la question du rôle de
l'église dans les pensionnats dépasse
maintenant les frontières du canada
lors de sa dernière visite en 2009
benoît 16 avait exprimé de la tristesse
à propos du traitement déplorable des
enfants autochtones dans les pensionnats
vous n'avez pas faire d' excuses
sauf qu'après les découvertes de 215
sépulture anonyme d'enfants à kamloops
mais aussi la commission vérité
réconciliation il enquête nationale sur
les femmes et les filles est celle ci
n'ait disparu bien des vérités ont été
étalées au grand jour
mais qui confirme que les découvertes de
cannes d'où son été un point tournant et
pas seulement pour les autochtones c'est
la première fois que j'ai vraiment vu
dans les nouvelles une message de sport
d'un réalisation de ce qui s'est passé
si des excuses du pape son tant attendu
c'est que les pensionnats ne sont pas
non plus qu'une affaire du passé
première femme élue grand chef du grand
conseil des cris elle souligne à quel
point l'impact de ces institutions fait
pour assimiler les autochtones se font
encore recensés aujourd'hui j'ai
vraiment eu
une relation difficile avec ma mère et
ma grand mère il y avait comme un un gap
entre nous plus moi les choses que j'ai
vécues à cause des impacts fiscaux
les représentants autochtones sont à la
recherche d' excuse mais ils veulent
aussi obtenir du concret mendy gorgue
mastic et d'autres veulent maintenant
que toutes les archives des pensionnats
que possède seize leur soit remise en
manque beaucoup d'informations
concernant les personnes qui ont étudié
les écoles que j'ai étudié mecs ont fait
au moins six accords le président de la
conférence des évêques du canada répond
que l'église est ouverte à le faire
raymond poisson c'est surtout que les
attentes envers le pape seront grandes
mais il est convaincu que le chef de
l'église prononcera les bons mots
vendredi
j'ai totalement confiance qu'il va dire
quelque chose de très clair et de très
direct à l'ensemble de ces personnes qui
sont venus de si loin pour le voir
phil fontaine et les autochtones du
canada attendre depuis longtemps des
excuses après des décennies de combat
cette fois ci pourrait enfin être la
bonne ici mathieu gaye et radio-canada
rome